chris is with us in baltimore maryland
hey chris welcome to the dave ramsey
show how can we help
thank you mr ramsey rachel um
long time listener followed your plan
i'm having trouble hearing you can you
speak directly into your phone please
i'm sorry sir i said a long time
listener i said
you know me and my wife followed your
guys plan we've been out of debt for
about six months
um that's not what i'm calling exactly
um we have a special needs show
and some things recently had happened
that i can't get in detail with but
essentially
we're at this point sitting on um
seven figures in our hand that was given
to us to help take care of our daughter
we've met with three or four financial
advisors so far
and every time i've gone in um to speak
to them or
the with co video phone calls or video
conferences
they only hair stand on my neck i don't
trust them i have a bad feeling about
them and
um a little emotional apologize just
looking for some advice on where do i
start and how do i go about
managing this cupcake with my daughter
long term very good
well you're a very wise man to trust the
hair on the back of your neck you're
very wise man to trust a feeling
uh we've got a saying around here from a
leadership perspective um we're dealing
with a situation inside the building if
something feels weird it's generally
because it's weird
you know that's why it feels that way
and so you know trust that
instinct uh what you're looking for is
not someone to do it for you
that you have to trust what you're
looking for someone to teach you
then you make the decisions and they do
what you tell them to do
after they taught you about 85 percent
of the people in the financial world are
taught to sell
not to teach stay away from them that's
why you felt like you needed to take a
shower after those meetings
because you were slimed by a sales guy
okay and so what you're looking for is
the heart of a teacher now you'll know
you found someone with the heart of a
teacher
when after meeting with them you know
something that you didn't know before
the meeting meaning you were taught
and you'll have this sense of peace
where they're not just grabbing at your
wallet
right yes sir okay and you want several
different kinds of people on your little
so to speak personal board of directors
you not only need a financial advisor
you also need a tax person
you also need a good estate planning
attorney
and wills need to be put in place with
special needs trusts and all kinds of
things here
to make sure this money set up for this
kid uh you also need a good insurance
person and that knows insurance that's
in your corner
and in each of these cases if you're
going to buy real estate at some point
you need a good real estate person
in each of these cases you want someone
that has the heart of a teacher
but because you're not accustomed to
managing seven figures it suddenly was
thrust upon you
you don't have the tools in your belt
and you've got to put a board of
directors in place
so to speak that are people that you can
tap they might not all ever meet
together that's not my point but
you can pick up the phone and go this is
my tax gal this is the guy that i work
with on real estate this gal does my
investments
and you got your you got your team built
and they all
have the heart of a teacher and you do
not put money in something until
you understand it and if you click smart
investor pro
or smart investor at davramsey.com for
investing advice
you'll find people we recommend they
don't work for us but in order to be
in the smartvestor program we vet them
very heavily
and they have to have that heart of a
teacher it's just essential because it
gives you a sense
of peace well it does and chris i mean
this money is being used for your
daughter with special needs so there's
like an emotional level of all of this
that's attached to it right so you feel
this level of responsibility
and i'm sure if she's not able to care
for herself if something happened to you
guys
really really feeling that
responsibility and that burden to do
this really well
and so i think that that's the key is
that not everyone in that industry is
slimy
there's some incredible ones but having
things in place that you
understand and you have a plan is what's
key and so for me
and this maybe even a question for you
dave but i'm like for a special needs
child
they do have specific wills and trust
set up
for that process so even finding an
expert in that world for as a mom
i'm just speaking from that side of my
heart would oh that would that would
give me peace no
that's an estate plan an estate planning
attorney to make sure your wills are set
in place because if something happened
to you and your wife
this money needs to go into a special
needs trust who's going to manage that
and what are the dictates of the trust
and you want to
tell the trustee how the money is to be
invested as a part of the trust being
formed upon your death
and then that child has got the money to
take care of them the rest of their
lives
if something happened to you guys so
really really good question